[Musique]
tout loupé ce sera toi que je testerai
aujourd'hui n'est comme le roi et la
reine ne le veux pas ça ce à quoi
[Musique]
là on est dans une très très belle
entreprise aujourd'hui pour parler d'un
smartphone sans strictement rien à voir
on est chez team est avec stéphane qui a
fait pas si vous vous souvenez ce n'est
pas un nombre déjà rencontré on s'est
vus ou les 1ers c'était c'était au psv
koala c'est ça gmail c'est une super
peut-être que je vous invite à aller
voir doit vous ai mis un lien dans la
description c'est de la montre connecter
pour enfants voilà un super outil jeu
sortira bientôt sait pas quand sortira
en octobre
en octobre magasin à partir d'octobre
ouais ça être là monde pour les enfants
sur les reconnecter donc pour faire vos
enfants des super héros qu on doit
s'écouler aujourd'hui j'ai la chance que
stéphane m'accueille chez lui voilà
j'espère qu'un peu d'espoirs était
toujours le bien sympathique et donc
aujourd'hui justement qu'on va parler
d'un smartphone je voulais présenter
tout à leur cellule et phonique ce1
c'est mon actualité oblige ores et déjà
sorti il ya quelques temps néanmoins
c'est un produit qui est la burqa plutôt
cool
alors c'est pas non plus un truc
révolutionnaire c'est pas le smartphone
de l'année très clairement par contre il
permet d'avoir un look très actuelle un
tarif défiant vraiment toute concurrence
pour ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va le
tester puis on va voir si au final ce
hub et phonique c'est intéressant rock
envoie un petit groupe de tuniques là
c'est cool
[Musique]
on est donc posée sur l'eau stop pour
parler de elephant x smartphone plutôt
cool quand vous regarde comme ça c'est
vrai qu'il a l'air tout d'un grand puis
franchement intéressant il ya un écran
de 5 85 pouces c'est une d'alipay ses
duels seller forcément les sur un
smartphone qui coûte vraiment pas cher
donc on va pas lui demander la lune
la définition de l'écran cdu 1512 par
720 pixels ratio 18,9 9e il occupe 91%
la face avant bon l'écran fonctionne
bien ça va là il ya vachement lumière et
pourtant ça marche pas mal
là il ya beaucoup de lumière je pousse
la luminosité à fond ça va ça va c'est
pas non plus un truc extraordinaire mais
ça va je suis fait une chaleur fin août
à paris c'est pas grave c'est plutôt pas
mal
alors après ce que j'aime bien dans ce
smartphone c'est un loup qui est très
actuelle c'est à dire que vous avez
effectivement la fameuse encoches sur le
haut vous avez une grande barre noire
rambarde et ça le petit menton parce que
forcément une question contraintes
techniques
on peut pas aller jusqu'en basse temps
ça va coûter est tout de suite beaucoup
plus fière point un peu négatif de
smartphones au point de vue design c'est
son épaisseur
il est vraiment très très épais on le
pardonne par rapport aux prix point
autre point un peu négative c'est le
poids il est tout de suite un petit peu
lourd
je le paie par rapport à un autre c'est
vrai qu'il est quand même un peu lourd
et ça c'est un peu ce qu'on peut lui
reprocher après une fois de plus pas non
plus demander la lune si nos deux amis
par actuelle vous avez ici
votre double caméra à l'avant ce
simplement une copine de l'iphone 10 eu
les fans l'attendent en digital bon à
l'arrêt il marche très très bien
vous avez rechargeant micro usb haut
parleur mono bouton de volume bouton
pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre prise
directe sur le dessus bon voilà après
ces standards
ça marche pas qu'on va côté performances
vous avez un processeur de médiathèque
c'est un 6763 oct accord 4 gigas de ram
64 go de stockage que vous pouvez monter
grâce à une carte microsd
jusqu'à 256 jega l'autonomie est pas
dégueulasse ça dépend bien évidemment
des ventres utilisation si vous
l'utilisez affront forcément le tome il
va fondre comme neige au soleil sinon
vous avez une batterie de 3300 milliards
d'erreur vous pouvez le tenir une
journée sur l'utilisation un petit peu
classique c'est à dire des petits jeux
mais pas trop gourmand des réseaux
sociaux d email un peu de navigation
quelques vidéos à regarder n'ai pas pu
donc très clairement c'est pas un
smartphone qui va destiner à des
personnes qui va quelque chose très
gourmand vous allez jouer pendant des
heures à des pays ou des choses comme ça
très clairement pas du tout par contre
si vous voulez smartphone pour
utilisation standard qui pense notamment
à des à des primo accédants ou à
quelqu'un qui veuille vraiment un
smartphone plutôt cool en termes de
design du monde tout cas très actuel ça
fonctionnera ne faut pas non plus trop
bien dans les points étaient plutôt cool
son smartphone vous avez un dos en verre
avec une recharge par induction bon
thank you points supplémentaires ça peut
être plutôt pas mal vous avez à
l'arrière ici une batterie de 16
mégapixels avec une batterie de 5
mégapixels une batterie de 5 mégapixels
à l'arrière d'un smartphone non ce
serait plutôt un capteur photo boylan je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé je vais
penser autrement la désole stéphane theo
bos on est hyper studio donc ça va tout
simplement je t'avais pour les faits
boké lorsque vous voulez prendre
quelques photos
n'attendez pas avoir la super qualité
avec ce smartphone très clairement à
terme de photos vidéos
le vrai problème c'est que vous avez pas
de stabilisation donc tout de suite ça
va bouger beaucoup vous allez pouvoir
filmer max en 1080p vous allez pouvoir
filmer aussi en 720p en dessous sur les
caméras avant
si ça va se taper les glaces si j'ai
bien pas porter de luminosité satis pas
trop mais là ça va
elle explique dans le métro
mal aimé
je séchais sur la mairie de côté
celles en béton
forcément pour l'aider
son autonomie
rien n'y fit
c'est pas gagné beaucoup
c'est génial
fraîcheur retrouvée
[Musique]
oh
les photos sont pas mal mais dès que ça
bouge et des cas pas des conditions de
luminosité qui sont assez c'est clair
qu'en tout cas où si la luminosité tout
de suite c'est compliqué à titre d'info
vous à l'ouverture maximale de f 2.2 pas
l'avant vous avez une caméra de 13
mégapixels vous avez plusieurs modes
vous avez du beauty mode pas mal de
choses fournir vraiment faire des photos
sympas alors je vous dis une fois de
plus un c'est pas vraiment smartphones
qui fait pour faire des photos
extraordinaires mais pour se souvenir et
puis surtout des partages pour les
réseaux sociaux ça fera bien à faire
côté ouest il tourne sous android
huit points aurait ôté pour l'instant
absolument aucune information sur le
fait d'une potentielle mise à jour sur
android 9
je serais surpris mais après tout
pourquoi pas bien évidemment il
complètement disponible en français vous
avez aussi du bluetooth 4.2 à
l'intérieur c'est un smartphone qui
comme ça en tout cas est plutôt cool on
va pas trop lui en demander rapidement
des amis non c'est pas le smartphone du
siècle mais c'est vrai que pour avoir un
produit qui est bien un tarif vraiment
intéressant celui d'ae photonics fait
vraiment à faire d'ailleurs si vous
intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description je vous parlais du
kwassa avec le poisson importance là
dedans l'aja l'iphone si c'est cela je
lis phonix même avec ma coque de
protection qui est assez épaisse il un
peu plus lourd il fait en tout 2 110
grammes alors si vous l'avez tout seul
dans votre poche dans un sac à main pas
forcément tout de suite vous déranger
mais c'est vrai comme ça en comparaison
entre non directement la main on se rend
compte qu'il ya quand même un peu plus
de poids le sud mais bon voilà peut pas
non plus tout avoir sur ce genre de
produit pour résumer pour finir il a sur
ce produit
moi je trouve cool à qui s'adresse je
vous dis s'adresse à des personnes qui
veulent des looks actuelle mais qui
veulent vraiment pas très cher leur
smartphone la finition est plutôt
correct plutôt pas mal le federer de la
recharge sans fil dessus c'est quand
même en point qui est pas mal pour un
peu négatif c'est vraiment sur la partie
photo vidéo faite par voie de
stabilisation le fait de prendre des
photos en faible luminosité
ça va franchement pas du tout le faire
si vous voulez capturer des selphy je
dirais ce qu'il veut mais de façon un
peu standard filmez vos amis films et
des soirées film est ce que vous voulez
ça marchera plutôt bien mais dès lors
que vous voulez faire des choses un peu
particulière un peu plus exigeante
ça va être ça la wii est en train de
vous filmer tout de suite je suis à
contre jour encore là il ya beaucoup de
lumière tout de suite là sur les toits
de paris
donc la voie là mais ça bouge l'image
tremble un petit peu c'est vraiment le
point de regret c'est que sur ce
smartphone parce que sinon je trouve que
dans l'ensemble
je pris le pas lui pas mauvais va plutôt
pas mal d'ailleurs dit moi ou ce que
vous en pensez
comment est ce que vous le trouvez cette
polyphonie qu est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter
ce qui vous intéresse et ce que vous
avez déjà eu des produits de la marque u
les fon vous marquez tout ça en
commentaire comme ça au moins on pourra
tout se faire une opinion
maintenant on va tester du point de vue
de l'audio voir si ça le fait bon je
pousse au fond forces et moyens du son
alors une fois de plus on est sur un
smartphone qui coûte pas forcément hyper
hyper cher il ya un peu de son là il n'y
a pas du tout de bruit à côté donc on
entend parfaitement bien si vous êtes
dans un lieu qui est un petit peu
bruyant j'ai peur que ce soit très très
moyen on va regarder quand même avec le
casque franchement c'est pas mal il ya
du sont gardées au top
ouais ça va il ya dix ans c'est pas
maintenant la qualité sonore avec le
casque ça marche très très bien il est
absolument aucun problème il ya beaucoup
de puissance
là par contre avec l'eau parleur mono
c'est un peu moyen une fois de plus on
essaiera smartphone à moins de 100 euros
pas trop leur demander je le trouve pas
mal c'est pas le téléphone le plus
lumineux très clairement bon en fait
plus vous dit en termes de prix on est
patiente extraordinaire si vous mettez
chose de très lumineux va falloir monter
considérablement en budget par contre
pour un téléphone d'entrée de gamme je
trouve qu'il est parfaitement bien faire
[Musique]
ok donc là je suis arrivée à l'aéroport
charles de gaulle
on va partir d'ici quelques instants
pour l'ifa à berlin
c'est un petit moment je vous en parle
ça y est c'est le moment où l'on va voir
plein plein plein de choses à l'ifa vous
allez voir c'est super cool il va y
avoir une conférence de sony va y avoir
du au nord voire acer philips on va y
avoir dj hi va y avoir on va le voir sam
sourire énormément de choses donc vous
invite à faire une seule chose c'est à
vous abonner à rester connectés tout
[Musique]